[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Star Wars Clone Wars
season 7 episode 2 video a distant echo
there were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
so we'll break it all down if you're new
to my channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the Clone Wars episodes it's the
final season and we're doing a Disney
Plus giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
if you think that Anakin notice that
Padme is super pregnant in this episode
obviously careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet we'll do
top 10 WTF and Easter eggs as we go
along there are a bunch of Easter eggs
so starting with number 10 it picks up
with them returning to the base on an
axis Anakin is pretty sure the council
will approve the mission to save Eko you
have to remember that there is still a
hierarchy the council still approves
these war missions that they go on
they're controlling a lot of the war
effort the reason why Palpatine set it
up that way is so that he could position
the Jedi as this faction that's
controlling the war so if things went
badly which sometimes they did per his
machination x' he could point at the
Jedi if the Senate got really pissed
that they lost a battle in blamed the
Jedi for that so it's all part of his
grand plan to turn popular opinion
against the Jedi as he slowly destroys
them quietly from the shadows obviously
we're not quite - Revenge of the Sith
territory yet number 9 we learned that
Anakin has been skyping with Padme
secretly but the clones obviously Rex
knows about it so he's been hiding it
from obi-wan Kenobi this whole time
which is funny because it turns out that
obi-wan Kenobi knows all about it too
but this just sort of gives you the
context for how they maintained their
relationship during the Clone Wars
because that lasted for a couple of
years they got married secretly at the
end of Attack of the Clones so when we
originally saw the prequels you were
just kind of left to wonder how their
relationship played out while Anakin was
busy running around the galaxy amidst
the Clone Wars turns out just a whole
lot of secret Skype sessions but I do
love Rex's reaction to this and when he
tries to mislead obi-wan Kenobi and
it'll be when is this like you're gonna
have to do way better than that you're
terrible at lying
Padme gives him some sage advice as
usual she's the more wise one out of
this relationship I think that's part of
the idea it gives you a better idea for
why she was able to become a senator
when she was so young but a lot of
Anakin's storyline is a mirror for Rex's
storyline like the whole
the episode the search for truth begins
with belief having believed having faith
so anakin needs to have more faith
speaking of easter eggs there's a poster
behind them I don't read Arabic
obviously like but I believe if you
decode this there's probably some sort
of Easter egg any time there's written
language on a big poster or something in
the background usually they find a way
to work in Easter egg into that so if
you are super hardcore and you can read
our abbess just write below what that
poster says in the comments number eight
though obviously obi-wan Kenobi lets us
know that he knew all about Anakin and
Padme the entire time of course he's not
a dumbass I love the way he sort of
calls Anakin on it too like he lets him
know I know exactly what's happening
when he says I hope you at least told
Padme hello and he gives Anakin pause
like he Hulk's in his tracks for a
second and thinks about it like wait a
minute how am I gonna play this oh well
we'll just brush it off like nothing bad
happened and he just walks away obi-wan
Kenobi gets really flustered at the fact
that he's not following proper Jedi and
military protocols throwing caution to
the wind it's just more classic Anakin
he's been like this the whole time but
obviously by the time we get to Revenge
of the Sith it's all about him trying to
save Padme when he starts getting the
forest visions of the future thinking
that she's going to die so this is just
laying the seeds for him really going
off-book so to speak in saving Palpatine
eventually becoming Darth Vader of the
Sith number seven WTF hunter tells
Anakin that he's not totally sure who
their special clone Force 99 commando
force reports to exactly but they have
worked with Commander Cody in the past
this is another one of those moments
where it seems like Palpatine pulling
the strings from behind where he's
playing both sides of the war to his
advantage they've addressed this in
previous seasons when they've done the
setup for order 66 where you have Count
Dooku talking to Emperor Palpatine when
he's acting as Darth Sidious like he has
his hood up and he's speaking with his
Darth Sidious voice it's just more the
idea that a lot of the clones don't
really know what's going on like clone
Force 99 isn't totally sure where they
get their orders from they just go in
they wreck stuff where they blow stuff
up you look in the background you see
wreckers lifting a gonk droid we saw a
bunch of those on the Mandalorian series
number 6 though the Dragon Riders of sky
co minor also reminding you of the myth
the swords of ancient Mandalore from the
Mandalorian series when he was trying to
ride the blerg
your ancestors rode the ancient mythos
or surely he
can ride this silly creature from the
Ewok movies that's right if you don't
remember the Borg is actually from the
Ewok TV movies we've never seen the pull
text before but they talk about their
quote unquote flying reptiles is
basically them flying dragons around
which is still pretty cool but they
carry Anakin off he loses his lightsaber
again which is a bit of a running gag in
Star Wars movies
Anakin losing his lightsaber obi-wan
Kenobi getting pissed off at him for
losing his lightsaber don't lose this
this weapon is your life they spent a
lot of episode one setting up clone
Force 99 s different abilities that they
have their super clones basically so
they're super badass so hunters able to
catch a ride and then it becomes number
five the clones versus the pole techs to
try and save Anakin but obviously it's a
bit of a misdirect like they caused a
big rock slide you see that they
probably take them pretty easily but the
whole idea is the pole techs don't want
to have anything to do with their war it
was pretty clear that they didn't want
to hurt Anakin but it takes tech to
coating their language to find out
exactly what's going on then Anakin is
able to explain to them what the techno
Union the separatists and wat Tambor are
doing on their planet no this is the
reason why the war came here because the
separatists are using it as a secret
base I kind of expected them to take
this storyline with the politics a
little bit deeper I expected there to be
a little bit more going on here but it
was really more about them just finding
common ground and helping them get to
that secret base so number four what
Tambor comes back if you don't remember
him he's been in a couple of the movies
he was in attack of the clones and he
was in Revenge of the Sith he also does
some stuff after the events of Revenge
of the Sith in the expanded material
when the separatists wound up losing the
war at the beginning of Revenge of the
Sith what happened is is that a lot of
their forces including wat Tambor and
some of the techno Union just went
around raising scorching the earth it
was very Lord of the Rings scorching of
the Shire kind of event and if you're
not a big Lord of the Rings fan don't
worry there's gonna be an Amazon Lord of
the Rings series that I'll be doing
episode videos for I'll talk about all
that stuff when that premieres but I
don't think that's going to be till next
year we learned the record even though
he's super badass super strong is afraid
of heights I think that's just giving
the other clones of clones force 99 more
personality that's the whole idea is
that they're different than the other
clones number 3 WTF classic Star Wars
trope as they're infiltrating the base
they tell them they're gonna do it nice
and quiet things are gonna go real
quickly they're gonna slip in
get echo come out but things go
completely off the rails immediately
they just start hacking their way
through all the droids a lot of cool
Anakin Skywalker lifesaver action in
close quarters
what Tambor also reminds them that he
allowed them to do this he predicted
their every move because of their quote
unquote secret algorithm but then they
call him on that bullcrap because they
know it's echo that's feeding them the
information they just don't know how
it's happening so number two Rex finds
echo and it's a huge WTF moment welcome
back echo haven't seen you in a couple
seasons looking a little bit different
we find out that the techno Union has
basically been taking the information
directly from echos brain this whole
time ever since the events of season 3
the reason why they turned him into a
cyborg is so that they could take the
information from his mind and control
him keeping him from escaping or have
they done to you I love the way they
play that heartbreaking scene obviously
Rex is probably the most well developed
clone character from the Star Wars saga
because his story extends all the way
into Star Wars rebels in the future but
I'll talk more about this when we get to
order 66 territory later in the season
I'm hoping that there's some overlap
with order 66 and they're trying to set
this up to let you sympathize more with
the clones when they're forced to turn
against the Jedi but if you don't
remember Rex is one of the characters
that did not turn against the Jedi
because he was able to remove his bio
implant chip you also noticed that a lot
of the echo cybernetic parts seemingly
foreshadow Anakin Skywalker's eventual
future when he's anointed Darth Vader
then his body is destroyed on moussa far
everyone post your high ground memes
then Emperor Palpatine uses technology
to turn him into a cyborg effectively to
keep him alive so number one huge WTF
what happened to echo after the events
of season 3 he remembers who he is but
doesn't immediately remember how he got
here how he was turned into a cyborg but
he does start reciting lines of dialogue
from the last episode that he appeared
in what happened is that after the
Republic forces left the separatists
came back in they found him barely alive
and then sold him to the techno Union
who then hacked his mind and has been
using him for information for the past
few seasons to give the separatists a
major advantage in all their big
battles all the information they were
able to steal from him clearly helped a
lot they kind of addressed that at the
beginning of season 7 episode 1 but
there's still a lot of big republic wins
in the war so it's not like he
completely turned the tide of battle a
lot of the end of the war will overlap
with the later episodes in the beginning
of Revenge of the Sith they did say that
there would be crossover with the events
of Avenger that said like anakin
learning the Padme was pregnant but we
don't know exactly how many episodes and
how far into the plot of Revenge of the
Sith this is going to go this is a bunch
of ahsoka a bunch of Mandalorian stuff
coming up so if you spotted any big
Easter eggs in the episode that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments and obviously my
episode 3 video will post next week I'll
put a link for all my Clone Wars
episodes in the description everyone
click here for my brand new Mandalorian
season 2 teaser and click here for my
brand new spider-man 3 marvel video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome this is the way
[Music]